want to mention something very quickly
happening right now on our team KOCO
social channels is a 24 hour livestream
right now we're playing all the hottest
games available in the Google Play Store
the stream started at noon today and it
goes until noon tomorrow that's right
it's 24 hours I did the math myself
whatever you're doing if you got a job
quit it so that you can follow this but
with a loved one leave that loved one so
that you can take part of this because
nothing like this has ever been seen
before I stopped by earlier today to
kick things off here's a clip explain
something here I'll just hold that
listen let me explain something just
hold that for 24 hours hold that okay
you what you get for that on eBay you're
still an eBay yes there's still an eBay
yes see I'm still with it I don't show
throw shade at Tiger say hi to people on
Twitter YouTube and Facebook okay hey
twitch facebook what else
YouTube YouTube YouTube face twitch book
so wait what happened what did the Bell
do the Bell signals and then you go up
and then you see look at this you know
what I stayed at this place once it's a
Bahamas alright I think we have to
figure out this puzzle which is maybe
there we go opened it up little car it
was a cardboard cardboard thing yeah
good thing you good thing that you found
the code because you can't get through a
cardboard block
you can touch my hair in VR you're
getting to touch Konitz hair tie my hair
in VR see that this looks also
disgusting he's gonna do something so
kind of pornographic gif put your kids
are up to remind you in the gutter yeah
see it's you imagine 24 hours of that
but only better we have a lot of other
special guests lined up we're not gonna
say who they are so be sure to check our
24 hour livestream until noon tomorrow
via Team Coco channels YouTube twitch or
Facebook
don't miss out don't be a square you
that's not the kids talk
you